el mundo entero padeció los efectos de
una recesión financiera Global en 2008 y
2009 pero bembernky la sufrió en carne
propia como presidente de la reserva
Federal entre 2006 y 2014 halló una
oportunidad de oro para aplicar sus
investigaciones previas sobre la
recesión mundial de 1930 que hoy lo
llevan a recibir el premio Nobel de
economía junto con Douglas Diamond y
Philip David
En un artículo de 1983 mostró con
análisis estadísticos y fuentes
históricas que las corridas bancarias
condujeron a quiebras y este fue el
mecanismo que convirtió una recesión
relativamente ordinaria en la depresión
de los años 30 las corridas bancarias
son retiros masivos de dinero que llevan
al colapso de los bancos Las
investigaciones de los laureados según
la academia sueca ayudaron a demostrar
como un rescate bancario en momentos de
crisis es clave para evitar colapsos
peores
en 2008 la gente entendió que parte de
lo que sucedió después de la quiebra de
liman Brothers que hubo pánico un miedo
al miedo en sí mismo y que la respuesta
para recuperar la confianza fue
importante para enfrentar esa crisis
los gobiernos de casi todo el mundo
rescataron a los bancos en 2008 lo que
generó un torrente de críticas debido a
que muchos consumidores sufrieron y
perdieron sus hogares mientras los
bancos se salvaban y sin duda lo que
pasó en el 2008 en Estados Unidos que
generaba una crisis financiera global
tuvo mucho que ver con comportamientos
poco prudentes de parte de los bancarios
y en algunos casos incluso delitos y eso
fue todo procesado en su momento y
también generó un cambio en La
regulación de parte de la reserva
Federal los tres economistas recibirán
lo equivalente a 885 mil dólares en
coronas suecas por haber logrado un
galardón que ha llegado a muchos
estadounidenses y solo a dos mujeres en
la historia